لاختراق التحصينات الاوكرانيه المتزايده
اعلنت روسيا عن صاروخ من طراز جديد سيدخل
العمليه العسكريه في اوكرانيا صاروخ براني
بوشك الجوي الفائق القدره بحسب وصف نائب
مدير عام شركه اخماش الروسيه الكسندر
كوتشين براني بوشك هو مخصص لتستخدمه
طائرات حربيه مثل
الطائرات والمروحيات الحربيه المزوده
بمنصات الصواريخ الجويه غير الموجهة
الصاروخ الجديد سينضم الى اسره الصواريخ
اس 8 عيار 80 ملي مترا فقدره براني بوشك
تتقدم على قدره سابقيه من هذه الفئه
الصاروخيه بمقدار خمسه الى سته اضعاف
يستطيع عبراني بوشك اختراق الحواجز
الخرسانيه وتدمير المنشات الدفاعيه
المحصنه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات